Hello everyone!
Hi FreshLiquid, Roy, Dylan, Michael, Astral, Reeze, Pug, Victor, Ruby, Rez, Ed, hi everyone!
Okay so, when I started, when I picked this game, and also hey Stevie, when I picked this game I was like, oh it looks cute!
That looks cute, cause I saw someone else playing, and I was like, oh that looks so cute, look it's pixel art, and like she's in a house.
And, oh it's like an adventure game, it's like a puzzle game.
And then I was like, I'm gonna play this on stream.
And then I, um, I put the tags down on the stream, I was changing categories, and the first tag that showed up was horror.
And I was like, how is this horror?
It's a fucking pixel game, how do you make pixels scary?
So I was like, oh fuck!
I mean, it's kind of puzzle game, with more panic I guess.
Oh shit, puzzles and horror, oh no!
That's the worst combination!
So I...
Hey, how is she, also thank you so much for the follow up prototype, I do appreciate it, thank you, thank you.
Have a, have a blood heart, thank you so much.
Alright, so apparently I'm gonna be doing puzzles, with a time limit.
And it's gonna be scary, so all three things, all my worst traits, combine together.
That's great.
That's...
I'm very much looking forward to it.
So, we're not, you're not late yet, I haven't started the play through yet.
Um, cause I wanna like procrastinate a bit.
Cause apparently the game's like 30 minutes long, and there's like a time limit.
So I basically have 30 minutes, to not die.
Uh, which, that means there's gonna be many attempts.
There's gonna be many attempts on this.
Cause there's a time limit too, and it's 30 minutes.
So I don't fucking know, how, how I'm gonna go through this.
Cause, first off there's puzzles in there, and I'm gonna get chased.
And then, I'm somehow gonna have to like make sure, you know what, I don't even care if I get the worst ending.
I just wanna finish this game.
I don't even...
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get the worst fucking ending.
Also hey Classic!
Alright, alright, are you guys ready?
Are you guys ready for me to start the game?
I'm not ready.
I have no idea what, what, what the plot of the story is.
I just know there's a...
You're a girl, it's pixel art, and it's spooky.
And that's all I know.
I'm trying to time this, sleep before the trip tomorrow, me right now sleeping in the plane.
It is oof.
Alright, alright, alright.
Spooky pixel art.
Oh, oh, okay.
Okay, alright, alright, let's go.
Oh, hey.
Oh.
Oh, I'm here.
How do I move?
Arrow keys?
Who the fuck uses arrow keys?
What the fuck?
Hey.
I'm a cute girl.
Alright, okay, we don't read here.
Oh, they used the watch...
We're not, no gacha today!
Oh, Astra!
So apparently there's like a time too.
So it's nine...
Okay, it's 9.50.
There's no gacha today, Astra!
I'm sorry!
Fucking get scammed!
Also, should I be like looking at the...
Alright, how do I open the door?
Shift to sprint?
Oh!
Ruff!
Hey.
Here you go, Ruff, just for you.
Get scammed, Astra.
Are you hungry?
I'll make some sandwiches.
Okay.
What's in here?
Oh, you're hungry.
Thank you so much for the follow, Artenza.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Have a...
I know there's a time limit, but fuck it.
Dude, this is a 30 minute...
I can't believe you've done this.
I wish I could stay longer, but I don't wanna go to sleep.
Alright, it's okay, Ed.
I do appreciate you coming...
Oh, hey, cat.
Meow.
I do appreciate you coming over and hanging out with us.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
I wanna know if dad will come home at midnight and you have a mom and a sister.
Well, I apparently have a cat too.
I don't know if he's gonna come home at midnight.
Okay, wait, give me a sec, guys.
I need to turn the volume down.
It is so fucking loud in my ears.
I can pour
this?
What do I do with this?
Is this milk?
What am I holding?
Wait, how do I...
Oh, I got a key.
Wait, no.
How do I get a key?
Key?
Oh, key.
Hey.
I hate this house.
Alright, fine.
I'm gonna go to bed.
Oh, wait.
I can...
Item?
Yeah, a little card.
Where do I go?
Okay, so...
Oh, oh.
Oh, god.
No, please, please.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Okay, bye.
Check it out.
What's this?
Yeah.
Oh, it's the crystal ball, guys.
It's just you start the game.
Alright, so...
We don't go in there.
We don't go in the rat room.
I've learned that rat room is dangerous.
The rat room is a no-no room.
I'm watching you sleep.
That's not creepy at all.
I don't have siblings, so I don't know if it's... Is it normal to watch your siblings sleep?
Because I don't have... I'm an only child, so I don't know.
I don't know if that's a normal thing to do.
I'm gonna have dinner, so I'll be lurking.
Alright, alright.
I need the milk.
You don't really have a choice when you share a room.
So do you watch your sister sleep when you're in the room?
That's really creepy.
I'm also an only child.
How do I pick up items?
Oh, hey.
Alright, so I learned that I don't go into that room.
That room is a no-no room.
Wait, okay, but like... My mom's gonna make me food, right?
Okay...
Where the fuck do I go?
Where the fuck do I go with this key?
There's only like three doors.
Here?
Like, how big is this house?
How big is this fucking house?
What?
There's only like seven rooms.
I don't know how to count though.
I assume there's like seven...
Okay, okay, if I pick this up and then I leave...
I should be fine, right?
Press space to open the...
Okay, I have a bucket.
What the fuck do I do with a bucket?
Okay...
I am so fucking...
Please, can I have some food now?
Please, mom.
Can I have some more?
Can I have some...
Oh shi- Oh!
Okay...
Are you okay?
I'm so okay.
Oh!
That's what the bucket was for!
Well, I tried.
Oh, my sister's dead too!
Oh!
Whoops!
I'm not a very good...
I'm not a...
I'm not a very good child.
You don't...
Oh, hey there.
What is this?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, hey there.
Oh and Shadow Man?
Hey Shadow Man!
Apparently
I'm not very good at saving people.
I'm not very good at this.
At least she died.
Why you sad?
Don't you hate it when that happens?
Man, don't you hate it when you slip and you just die?
Don't you just hate that?
Okay, okay, I got this.
I got this.
Okay, I need to give milk, milkies to the cat.
How was I supposed to know this is a puddle?
It's just fucking three thingies!
It's just like three dots on the floor!
What the fuck?
What child would know what that is?
Thank you so much for the follow milkshake.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Have a, have a mutter.
Maybe we can get some- dude I already- I used the- I used the lizard.
They've already died so- Excuse me?
Oh my god.
I gave you milk and this is how you repay me?
Oh okay, nevermind.
Good cat.
Wait, how do I pick up?
Oh, hey.
I keep forgetting how to- I keep forgetting how to pick- Please feed me.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, but like- Where did I get the bucket again?
Oh, hey sis.
Oh yeah, I can like look through- look through the things, right?
I am so fucking confused.
How is this a 30 minute game?
People already died in like less than five minutes.
I don't understand how people can play this game for 30 minutes.
People already died in like five minutes.
Oh, hey, whoa, whoa, Shadow Man!
Thank you so much for the follow, Ichigo.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much for the follow, Ichigo.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, Shadow Man.
Bye, Shadow Man.
Oh shit, wait, wait, I need to get the bucket.
I need to save my mom.
Um...
How do I-
I did this.
Okay.
How do I pick you up?
Mom, look what I did!
Look what I did, mom!
Oh.
Well then.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Oh, da - Wait, but how do I save my- Oh!
Okay.
Bye.
I'm not very good at this, guys.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Gotta get the bucket.
Here?
Hey, how do I- How do I- How do I get out?
Hello.
Okay, well then.
Now that my mom and my sister is dead...
Oh!
What the fuck?!
Okay.
Hi, mom.
Okay, well, she's- Hey, she didn't die!
She's okay!
Alright.
Now I know why it took 30 minutes for- Now I know why it took 30 minutes, chat.
Now I know why this game took 30 minutes.
Alright, alright, alright.
I got this.
Okay, okay.
So, I have to get to the- I forgot to defrost the turkey before mom gets home.
Okay, but how do I get- Okay, but how do I get- Okay, okay.
I need cats for- to get the milk.
Alright,
alright, alright.
I got this.
We can speedrun this now.
This time I won't fuck up, I swear.
Alright, cat, wake up.
Wake the fuck up.
Wake up, cat.
This time, this will be the speedrun.
This is it.
You're gonna see what AGLS is playing right now.
AGL- AGSLSG is playing right now.
They're gonna fucking submit my name.
My speedrun.
And I'm gonna be on stream.
Please, please.
Please, wake up.
I need the key.
Okay, please stop talking to me.
Please.
Give me the key.
Okay, and then- And then we do this.
And then we go out here.
Who the fuck is Shadow Man?
I'm so confused over Sh- Oh no.
Oh, wait, I think I already fucked up.
Wait.
How do I- How do I- How do I- Oh.
I think I already fucked up.
Wait, how do I- How do I save my mom?
Wait, I fucked up already.
Wait.
I think I already fucked up.
How the fu- How do you mop this?
Okay, okay, wait, wait.
If I keep slipping on it.
Oh, if I keep slipping on it, will it dry out?
Will it dry?
Maybe I keep slipping.
Okay, alright, mom.
I'm sorry.
That's how you do it, right?
Mom, I'm sorry, mom.
I'm so sorry.
If I keep slipping on it, will it help?
I'm sorry.
Oh, wait, I can save my sister.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, if I can't save my mom, I'll save my sister.
If I can't save my mom, I'll save my sister.
Alright, I'm sorry, mom.
I'm so sorry, mom.
Alright, alright.
Okay, bye.
Oh my god, I'm so smart!
I had to keep slipping!
I had to keep slipping on it to save her!
Holy shit!
I am the fucking smartest gamer out there.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, okay, bye.
Um...
Hey, okay.
Well then.
Okay.
I'm gonna drop it here for the rat.
Ratty!
Rat!
I got you food, rat!
I got you food!
Please eat my food!
Yeah!
Oh.
Alright, you know what?
I wanted to be an only child.
I wanted to be an only child anyway.
Shit!
It's okay.
I wanted to be an only child.
I'm okay with that.
He's such a fallabury!
Oh!
Cat, are you okay?
What's that?
Cat?
Is cat okay?
Oh, cat's dead!
Oh shit!
Wait, cat's dead!
Wait!
Oh!
I'm so sorry!
Wait, where's mom?
Mom?
Oh, no!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
What does this do?
Swing?
Let me swing.
Hey.
Mom?
Oh.
You've never played our heart game.
You hear our play.
Why do you lie?
I think, I think I got bored.
Oh, don't.
Well then.
Oh.
Now I understand how this took 30 minutes to fucking play.
Damn, she bored me.
Okay, alright.
I now know how to save my mom.
I don't know what to do with my sister though.
I don't think I need a sister.
I, I, I don't think I need a sister, so that's okay.
Drink the milk.
Wake up.
I don't think I need a sister, so that's okay.
Yeah, I mean, I'm pretty perfect with this.
Yeah, sisters are optional.
We don't need a sister.
That means more presents for me.
I mean, I don't know what it's like to have siblings, and I think I like, I like being an only child.
She keeps getting squished.
I think, I think like, being an only child is pretty fun.
I get to have Wait, I was gonna say something really fucked up.
I'm saying like, what are you gonna do?
Huh?
I'm their only child.
They can't do shit.
They can only rely on me.
Hey, Rain!
Okay, I need to cycle the items.
Okay, and I gotta slip on it.
I gotta slip on it, so... Hey, Taylor!
Okay, if I slip on it, it'll be okay.
I just gotta keep slipping.
Just gotta keep slipping.
Sorry, this makes you feel incurred by my now.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
Okay, and then...
And then what do I do?
Pick it up?
What if I just do this?
Oh.
Okay, apparently not like that.
Okay, and then I just gotta keep slipping.
Also, these were your little follow, Taylor.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, Mom.
Mom, make me some sandwiches.
Oh, the buckets for the cat!
Oh!
Alright, Mom.
I did it!
Okay, and then I gotta pick up the sandwich for the uh...
for the...
for the rat.
Alright, rat.
Here's a sandwich.
Get in here.
Get in here, rat.
Get in here!
Oh, she's dead!
Okay, okay.
Well, she's dead now.
Let me... I don't give a fuck about you for now.
Let me go save the...
Let me go save the cat.
I'm sorry, sister.
I don't... I don't care about you.
Alright, anyway.
There's a fucking...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Rat, rat, rat, rat, rat, rat.
Sandwich, sandwich, sandwich.
Eat the sandwich.
Yes, yes, yes.
There we go.
Alright.
Alright, we got everything.
We got everything we wanna do.
Alright, the... Oh, okay.
We have everything we need.
Alright, we don't care about the...
the girl.
Okay, so the cat's alive.
Do you remember me?
I actually don't, Mike.
I actually don't.
I'm sorry.
Alright.
And now we gotta swing...
the axe.
Ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Ho, ho!
What?
What's that sound?
Oh, I have another sandwich.
Can I pick up the sandwich?
No.
Alright, let's... Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, please.
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Hey, Arlo!
How the fuck do you beat this game?
I don't understand!
How do...
How do I beat this game?
Do I just stay in the rat room?
I'm just gonna stay in the rat room.
I'm just gonna...
Alright, I don't know how to save the sister.
I don't know how to save the mom.
As long as I save the cat, that's all that matters.
That's all that fucking matters.
I just need to save the cat.
All is safe in the rat room.
Alright, just stay in the rat room.
The rat room is safe.
But like...
Alright, cat.
The rat and the cat are the only family we need.
Apparently it is...
Apparently Apparently Apparently it is a horror game.
Oh look, he's going to follow Firestone.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, cat.
Get the fuck up.
Cat, I need the...
I need the key.
Cat.
Oh, there we go.
There's cat.
Okay.
Alright, then I need a bucket.
Like in the only child simulator.
I mean, you're not wrong.
You're not wrong.
You're not wrong about this.
You're not wrong about that.
Alright.
Okay, I just need to slip on it a few times.
I just need to slip on it a few times.
There we go.
Okay.
What happens if I turn off the lights?
Alright, green.
Thanks for hanging out with us.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
How do I do this?
Can I...
Can I push the...
No, I can't.
I guess we'll...
Bye, sister.
Hahahaha.
Guess I don't have a sister anymore.
Bye-bye.
I need that sandwich.
Ummm...
What the fuck do I...
Wait, what's this bullet about?
Oh!
Do I do...
What do I do here?
Well then, bye.
Bye.
Hahahaha.
I guess I do that.
Well, we don't have a sister anymore.
So that's okay.
Alright, bye.
Oh shit, wait.
I need to pick this up.
Alright.
Yeah, my cat's my family now.
Bye, sister.
Please, please eat this sandwich.
Oh, thank you, thank you.
Oh!
Oh, I'm sorry!
Oh, no!
No!
Please!
Hahahaha.
Please, I just wanna make it.
I just wanna... I just wanna be saved.
Hahahaha.
Please, I just wanna be saved.
Chatelman.
Hahahaha.
How many times do I have to do this?
How do people speedrun this game?
Hahahaha.
How do you do it?
Okay, alright.
Trial and error.
Hahahaha.
There is a lot of trial and error.
There's a lot of errors.
Hahahaha.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Hahahaha.
Oh!
No!
Alright, we don't need... we don't need rat room.
We don't need rat room.
Hahahaha.
Fuck you, cat.
I fucked it up already.
Hahahaha.
Okay, if I keep doing this, will the ghost be angry?
It's okay.
We don't need rat.
We don't need...
Who's own house?
I have several complaints.
You know what?
I... Okay, I just realized.
Wait, can I die from this?
Oh, I can.
Ah.
Well then.
Hahahaha.
I can die from this.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, alright, alright.
Speedrun.
Let's speedrun this.
Wait, I can't believe we've only been streaming this game for five minutes, chat.
Holy shit, I am a fucking guy.
Alright.
We need this.
And then...
My cat.
Please.
Here we go.
And then...
Wake up.
Hey, Muffy!
Okay, and then...
I drop you here.
And then I need to get the milk.
I might go doing... Like, I am actually like doing this on autopilot now.
Hahahaha.
This is on fucking autopilot.
Please.
Cat, wake up.
Cat, please.
I need the key.
Please, cat.
Please.
Hahahaha.
This is an actual speedrun now.
Alright.
Bike rat.
Okay, and then I need a...
What a lovely house.
Only... only twelve horrific murders took place.
Exactly.
Only twelve.
I think we have a very good track record.
It's only twelve...
twelve deaths.
Not that much.
What the fuck do I do here?
I want to save my... Okay, I don't really give a shit about my sister.
But like...
Hahahaha.
It would be nice if my sister didn't die.
Omni!
Thank you so much for the...
for the... for the raid!
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, sister.
Sister, please.
Oh, what if I just keep talking to you?
Sister, if I keep talking to you, will you not die?
Do you have a good stream, Omni?
Alright.
If I keep talking to you, will you be okay?
Look.
I hate what he did.
I hate these walls.
But if I keep talking to you, you'll be alive, right?
Hahahaha.
Please, don't die!
Please, stop playing the piano.
Hahahaha.
If you just stop playing... Oh shit, wait, wait, wait.
I just realized.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I think she's gonna die from this.
Oh, she's fine.
Okay.
And I can't... I can't...
die, right?
Exactly!
Hahahaha.
Isn't that how it works?
What the fuck is this frog doing here?
What do I do with this frog?
You saved her?
Hahahaha.
Masaya, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
Have a blood heart.
Have some blood hearts.
Alright.
Oh, Shadow Man.
Hey, Shadow Man.
I don't know how to pick the frog up.
Well, we don't give a fuck about the frog.
Apparently.
So...
Oh, hey there.
So the sister's gonna die.
And I don't know what to do about that.
I don't know what I can do about the sister's death.
Hahahaha.
She's dead.
Now eat your sandwich.
Wait, wait, wait!
I... There's the sandwich!
Please!
Just eat the sandwich!
Hahahaha.
Alright.
So, that was karma.
Cause I was like, bye bye sister.
And I...
You stole your little follow, Hannah.
Alright.
Dude, how the fuck...
You said you were meeting in the sun.
How the fuck do you do this?
I... I...
Everyone just keeps dying!
You're my little frog champ.
Why do people keep dying around me?
I don't understand.
Alright.
And then here's the milk.
I don't
know what to do with you.
Ummm...
What do I do with you?
Hahahaha.
Here you go.
Cat, wake up.
I need the key.
I don't... I've been playing for 36 minutes.
I've been doing this for 36 minutes.
Is this insanity?
Is this... I thought I could...
I just wanted to get an ending.
I don't care how many people die.
I just want this game to end.
Hahahaha.
I don't care how many people die.
I just want this game to end.
Hahahaha.
Ohhh, I should...
Okay, then she's gonna die through the bear trap!
I don't care how many people I sacrifice.
I just want to end this game.
I just want this game to end.
Hey, please, please...
Please stop.
Okay, so I got everything I need.
I just don't know how to... is she gonna die?
Well then, at least she's okay.
At least she's not crushed.
That's alright.
She's okay.
Oh shit, do I crush the frog?
Alright, frog.
I'm sorry.
Oh.
Well then.
It's okay, I saved her.
She's safe.
And then I take this, and then...
It's okay.
She's okay.
I think being... I think dying from a bear trap is... look, she's happy.
Oh!
Oh, she's not happy!
She's not happy!
I don't think she was...
I don't think she was happy, guys.
Okay, she was definitely not happy.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Okay, so what I've learned was that she was... she was not happy.
She was definitely not...
Oh, please!
I can't run!
Oh, no!
Please.
Alright, eat the... eat the sandwich.
Please eat the sandwich.
Oh, oh, no!
Please don't!
Why can't you eat the sandwich?
All I want you to do is eat!
Why can't you eat?
You're making... I thought I got it down.
I thought I got everything down!
Thank you so much for the follow.
You appreciate it.
Thank you.
Alright.
Okay, I got this down.
Did he just... oh, you just rubbed your face too close to the mouth.
Okay.
How do I even save her?
I don't understand.
What do I do with this?
Okay, if I put it here, it should be okay, right?
Alright, I... I'll... I'll put this here for now.
And then...
Okay, alright, alright.
Come on, cat.
Hook up!
Thank you.
Okay, and then I got to go get...
Easy ride.
This is my turn.
I just wanted to be an only child!
Is my mom still here?
Is my mom gonna die?
Oh no, she's okay.
Is that too much to ask for?
I just wanted to be an only child.
I'm gonna call it here.
My back is killing me today.
Have fun.
Don't murder anyone else.
Oh, I don't know about that.
Can I kill a cat here?
No, I shouldn't.
The cat's the only one I know how to keep alive.
No, you feed the rat the sandwich.
But then I don't know what else to do after that.
I don't know how to save my sister.
So, it's okay.
We don't care about her.
We just want the sandwiches.
I can!
I tried to.
I tried to crush it.
Alright, I haven't killed the mom.
But the mom just disappeared.
So I don't know where the fuck she goes.
Also, thank you so much for the follow links.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, mom.
Give me that sandwich.
So I can feed the rat.
So I can feed the rat again.
It worked with the... also thank you so much for the follow links.
It worked with the...
It worked last time.
I just don't know why it's not working now.
The rat for some reason doesn't want to eat my sandwiches for some reason.
I don't know why.
I think my sandwiches are perfectly good.
Alright, bye.
Alright, here.
Here's the rat.
Here it is.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay.
Oh my god, I got a shadow man.
Please!
Shadow man!
Please, I just got it to work.
Shadow man, please!
Well,
I don't care about you.
I was gonna be so angry.
I worked so... Shadow man, please!
Please, I just got this.
Please.
I just...
Alright, anyway.
Anyway.
And then, what do we do here?
Alright, and then I do like put it here somewhere.
Oh, she's... oh.
Is she okay?
Wake up, mom!
Mom!
Oh!
Oh, bye mom!
So that's where mom...
Oh, okay.
How do I... How do I do this?
Okay, so that's where mom went.
How do I get rid of this?
How do I do this?
Please!
Oh, shadow man.
Shadow man!
Please!
Shadow man, please!
I just want to get... Oh, hey, I did it.
Okay.
Ani, thank you so...
Is that it?
What do I do?
What do I do now?
Thank you so much for the little sub.
I do appreciate it.
What do I do?
Daddy's home.
Hey, daddy.
Okay, there's a bear trap.
Yeah!
Dumbass.
Oh!
Oh, I'm the dumbass!
I'm the dumbass!
Wait!
Oh, no!
Ahahaha!
Ahhh.
You're gonna get the taste of Apollo.
Dumbass.
Ahhh.
Ahhhh.
I'm so sad.
I can't believe.
I thought I got it.
I thought I was like 800 IQing this shit.
I thought I was so smart.
How do I do this?
I didn't appreciate you bear trapping this boy.
I was like haha he's dead.
So mom gets eaten by a fridge and dad is a face eating floor of the mat.
This family's got it all.
Thank you so much for the follow, Pastel.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Alright, cat.
Eat your milk.
Get the fuck.
Dude, I hate how this takes 20 years.
It takes him 20 years to get his milk.
Get his cat ass off.
The cat's the only one I can save.
I can't even tell this is a horror game where a main main will never win game.
I'm never gonna win.
It's simpler than man get caught in a bear trap.
Okay.
Well...
It still goes to P.K.S.E.
Learn something new every time so as long as you keep learning, experiment, I see that's progress.
Exactly.
The only thing is that our sister doesn't live but that's okay.
I've always wanted to be an only child.
That's okay.
Like, I tried to do something about it but look.
Doesn't let me do anything.
I can't save him so it's fine.
I don't need her.
What does she even do for my house?
Nothing.
Like, what?
Do I kill the frog?
I also learned that you can kill the frogs but it doesn't do shit.
Like, it just comes back.
Oh, thank you so much for the follow, Kenny.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you.
What do I need?
Oh, I need sandwiches.
Yes.
You're doing great, sweetie.
I'm trying my best.
Drop me the bullet bomb.
Cat.
Lord, wait.
It's a cat.
Faster?
I don't think so.
I tried dropping it before.
You only won once.
Happy birthday, sweetie.
Today is my birthday.
Happy birthday, Snake.
Can we get some happy birthdays and chat for Snake real quick?
Here's some happy birthdays.
Oh, Shadow Man.
Hey, Shadow Man.
Okay.
Alright, I have the sandwich.
Alright.
Rat, rat, rat, rat, rat, rat, rat, rat.
Here.
Here's your dumbass sandwich.
Rat.
Rat!
No!
Shadow Man.
Alright, now we gotta... we don't care about you.
Bye.
And then we gotta get the... we gotta get the... oh shit.
Wait, wait, wait.
We gotta do this.
We gotta...
Alright, and then we gotta go get the axe.
Yeah, but I could always come back in.
I could always come back...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, there you go.
We're fine.
We don't care about the sister.
Okay, wait a minute.
I can save my... I think I can save my mom here.
I can save my mom.
Don't worry, mom.
I'll chop her head.
Mom, I'll save you too.
Mom, look at this.
Watch this, mom.
Look at this.
I got this.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah!
You're welcome.
You don't give a fuck.
Oh shit, Shadow Man.
I did it!
I saved mom!
Okay, alright, alright.
I did it.
Oh, oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
There we go.
I'm so good at this game.
What do I do now?
Okay, what do I do now though?
I don't know what to do!
Mom!
Alright, alright, okay, okay.
I got this.
Alright, dad's gonna be here.
Daddy's home.
Yeah, get in here.
Get in here.
Stupid.
Yeah, that's right.
Bye.
Whoa, dad!
I got mom!
Don't worry, I have mom!
I have mom!
What are you gonna do?
Mom!
I saved your life!
What the fuck's the point of saving mom?
What the fuck was the point?
What the fuck was the point of saving mom?
She's not gonna do shit!
I'm so sad.
Alright, so mom can die.
At least I learned mom can die.
Mom can die.
We don't need to give a fuck about her.
We don't need to give a fuck about mom.
All those efforts wasted on her.
What's the point?
All she's good for is making sandwiches.
Cat!
Oh, it does wake him up!
Roy, you were right!
I'm sorry for doubting you!
Okay.
Alright, so I woke up cat.
Alright, get your fat ass off.
Alright.
Okay, and then I need, I need key.
I need key.
Alright, and then, and then I need to unlock key.
And then I need to pick this up.
And then I need to, what the fuck do I need to do?
Um, oh yeah, I need to cycle this and drop it here.
Alright.
Can I make the doll in the rat room?
Oh shit, yeah, I should try that.
It doesn't even make me become half the man he used.
Can I?
No, nothing drops there.
What if I do this to my mom?
What happens?
Mom.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright, mom doesn't give a fuck, apparently.
Mom doesn't care.
Alright.
Give me the bear trap.
Give it to me.
Alright.
What the fuck do I do with this?
Okay, and then I need to wait until...
What do I do here?
Oh, I just wait.
I just need sandwiches.
I just need, I just need the sandwiches.
I don't give a fuck about light switches.
Oh, it's spooky now.
Oh, it's spooky.
Oh, what are you gonna do?
What if I turn off the lights here?
Sister, are you gonna keep playing in the dark?
Don't be dumb.
Don't play in the dark.
Sister!
Is this annoying?
This is annoying?
Sister!
Okay, she doesn't give a shit.
Well, I don't know.
I've given up.
I just need...
We don't need her.
We don't need her, guys.
All we need is our cat.
All we need is our fucking cat.
We don't need anyone else.
Apparently, this is due shit.
Anyway.
And then... sandwich.
Here.
Eat the sandwich.
Yeah, that's right, bitch.
Okay.
I'm sorry for calling you a bitch.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Yeah, bitch.
I don't know what to do after this.
All right.
You know what?
I'll save the mom.
I have nothing else to do right now.
Mom, you're lucky.
I have nothing else to do.
Oh, she's asleep.
Mom, you're lucky.
I have nothing else to do right now.
What do I do?
Can I just kill her?
Whoa!
Well then.
Okay.
Bye.
You know what?
Oh!
Oh, I forgot the
cat!
Oh!
Oh, no!
I forgot
the cat!
I'm so sorry!
Oh!
I killed the cat and the mom!
Look, I just need... I need this to fucking hurry up.
Look, it's not my fault.
Shadow Man, I don't have time for your shit.
I don't...
Okay, there we go.
All right.
I need to swing my hammer.
Do this?
What?
I just wanted to open the closet.
I just wanted to...
Girl, thank you so much for the raid!
Thank you!
I got worried again.
Well...
We don't need the mom.
We don't need the...
We've learned that we don't need the mom.
We don't need the sister.
We might need the cat, but I forgot about the cat there.
I keep forgetting.
How do I do this shit?
All right.
So we don't need a lot of people.
We just need the cat.
I hope you had a good stream, Crow.
I hope you had a good stream.
All right.
Don't worry.
Bam.
Yeah, that's right.
Wake the fuck up, cat.
We don't need... Yeah, we don't need anyone other than the cat and the rat.
What do you mean back?
I did!
I hugged the back wall and then she bored me!
She bored me!
Did you not see the board?
I was at the back.
This is the back.
I was over here.
I was... I was right here.
And then she bored me.
With the cat and the rat.
It's gonna be some interesting PDA meetings.
What am I doing?
Oh shit.
Wait.
Okay.
Boom.
Oh, that's not it.
There we go.
These are the followers.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Hmm.
No, no, no.
You put the sandwiches.
You put the sandwiches on the rat.
Is he gonna establish his sister to do anything?
Do we care about the sister though?
I don't...
I don't... We don't care about the sister though.
Like, I'm not gonna do shit about her.
I'm not gonna save her life.
You know... Oh, hey.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I wanna kill the frog.
I don't know what it does, but I just wanna kill the frog.
Oh, wait.
That's not it.
I don't understand.
Spatial... Spatial... Wait.
Spatial... Wait, can I...
Why can't I pick it up?
Oh, the frog has the bowling ball now.
Well then.
I guess the frog has the bowling ball now.
And then I'll hit you down here.
Alright.
I need my sandwiches.
Now is the time to deconfirm.
I can't... I can't pick up the bowling ball anymore.
I don't think they want me to crush the frog.
I don't think they like that.
Now I can save the mom.
Well, I don't really care about the mom.
To be honest.
So all we're gonna do is...
Kill every kind of scary, to be honest.
No, no, no, no, no.
This is all planned.
Like... I didn't kill anyone.
She's just dumb.
To be fair, I didn't kill anyone.
She's just stupid.
Okay.
Alright.
I need to save the cat.
I just need to save the cat.
Okay.
Alright.
I saved the cat.
I did it.
Alright.
And then...
I guess I can save mom too.
I guess... I guess I can save the mom too.
Bye.
No.
She doesn't go in.
She doesn't...
I poured water on her and then she freaked out and died.
And...
I'll save the mom once.
Okay?
I'll save her again.
Please come out.
Oh,
there you are.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Stupid.
Alright.
And then we gotta...
And then we gotta do this thing.
Alright.
I'm just gonna wait until this works.
Can you pick up... No.
I tried picking up the sandwich.
But I can only pick up one.
I have no idea.
We don't care about the mom.
She does nothing for me.
I... I... I like led dad over.
And then dad... he was just like...
Bye.
Look at this.
You liar!
Roy, you fucking liar!
Oh, hey.
Daddy's home too.
Look at that.
He's...
Oh.
Hey, look.
Daddy's home.
Yo.
Thanks, dad.
Yeah.
Thank goodness he's here.
Never trust Roy.
Oh, he's home with both our sadness.
Now I... Hey, look.
It's okay.
Mom's still alive.
I saved mom.
That's all that matters, right?
I fucking saved that bitch.
Alright.
Please.
Get the fuck away.
Alright.
Okay.
And then...
Wait.
How do I...
Key...
Okay.
And then pick up.
And then...
And then what do I do?
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
I gotta...
I just wanna...
Let me win this game.
Please.
I don't care people...
I don't care that people are dead.
I... I don't care that I've killed...
I've killed many people.
I... I can't.
I have to wait for the sandwiches.
Um...
I have to wait for the sandwiches for the rat.
And then...
Alright.
How do we distract the lady from the bathroom?
I don't know.
I don't know what to do about that.
I need...
Okay.
So...
So I don't know what to do here.
I'm stuck here.
This is where I'm stuck at, guys.
This is the...
Well, maybe if I...
Do I... If I go to my sister's room...
Sister...
Hey, sister.
Yes, I know you hate your life.
Like...
There's nothing I can do here, though, in her room.
Yeah, her room is meaningless.
I have to...
I have to get the sandwiches, though.
I don't have the sandwiches.
How does this face do?
I have no idea.
I can't...
Um...
I can't go in the room without my sandwiches because of the rat.
I need the sandwiches so the rat will be satisfied and won't eat me.
And it grows.
I made sandwiches.
Oh, I made sandwiches.
And then...
Okay.
So...
I'll show you guys what I did last time because we don't give a fuck about the...
We don't really give a fuck.
Actually, no.
I'm not.
I want to save the cat.
So I want...
I actually sort of want to save the cat.
So...
Here.
Take this.
I'm going to...
I'm going to give this to Elisar.
Thank you so much for the gift!
This is Elisar!
Can I get some bark knives real quick?
Can I get some bark knives real quick for...
For Elisar?
Okay.
And then we put this...
Woo!
Bye there!
Okay.
And then we don't give a fuck about the mom.
We don't give a fuck about...
And use your spring.
You can grab the axe, just put it on the rack and get you and cut the...
Cut the boards?
Well...
That...
I don't give a fuck.
Maybe if I leave the dad, if I leave the dad to crazy lady.
Then maybe she'll war him instead of me.
Right?
Maybe she'll war him.
Oh I forgot the cat again!
I forgot the cat again!
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry.
Oh!
What the fuck!
Oh he did not like that.
He didn't like that I forgot the cat.
Oh he was not happy about that.
He was not happy about that.
He's our only family.
I told you this was...
You would think that.
This was supposed to be a 30 minute game.
It was a fucking lie.
Angry.
Shadowman was not happy.
He was not happy about that.
Okay.
Alright.
If I do this.
Boom.
And then I'll get the axe first.
Right?
You guys want me to try getting the axe first.
Okay.
Let's try.
Let's try this.
Just don't use my sprint.
I just don't use my sprint.
You liar!
Am
I just bad at this game?
You have the time man.
God damn.
Me and time.
Alright.
Wake the fuck up.typ
lruot what's the easiest way To win this game ?
I don't care how many people die.
I don't care how many people.
It's hard.
Oh my God.
I don't care how many people die in this world.
I just want to win.
I just want this game to be over.
I need to sleep right at work tomorrow.
I'll watch the VOD and see how cute I get to the game.
Alright, thanks for the rating.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I hope you have a good night's rest from your work tomorrow.
Alright.
But it's what you have to do it.
I have to do that?
To win the game?
Please.
Is there no other way?
Okay, I'll do it again.
No, actually no.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm just gonna do my usual strat.
I'll do my usual strat.
Yeah, but then what about dad?
What about dad though?
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
Go.
Stupid rat, stupid rat, stupid rat.
Yeah, bitch.
Stupid rat.
Alright, alright.
Oh, and then I can like... I know.
Oh, I see, I see.
And then... um...
Um... Oh, I know.
I know, I know.
I got this.
My brain.
My brain is getting bigger.
I know what to do.
Yeah, okay, and then I pick this up.
And then...
Oh, but then I'm gonna save the sister.
Then I'm gonna save the sister.
We don't give a fuck about the sister.
Alright, sister.
Here's your stupid sandwich.
Sister!
I got you a sandwich!
Is she gonna die?
No!
Well then.
I got your sandwich, sister.
Well...
It appears that... oh...
It appears that it didn't work.
Guys.
It appears that the sandwich did not want a night limit.
That wasn't it.
That... well then.
Sandwich...
does not save the sister.
Well, I've learned.
I've learned that... How do I win this?
How do I fucking win this?
Please!
Someone backseat!
Please backseat this game for me!
I hate backseat gamers!
This is just pain.
This is just pain at this point.
All I feel is pain.
I swear, okay.
If we don't figure out a solution by the 15 minute mark, we're fucking done with it.
We're fucking folding up a tutorial.
We've been stuck on this one area.
I have a doll?
Oh wait, I should save my mom first.
I should...
But I don't want to save... okay, but the thing is, I don't need to save my sister.
My sister's optional.
Like, we don't need her.
There's no reason to have her in our lives.
Oh shit, I need the bowling ball.
We don't need the sister in our lives, so that's just an optional thing.
I want to be an only child.
Just kill her with a bear trap, part of a sub, but then what about dad?
What about dad?
No.
Whoa!
Will you hold me okay?
Bye!
My sister.
Oh, she doesn't want you.
Yeah, that guy's new.
Yeah.
Wait, what if I put her in the room?
I'll put her in here.
I'll just drop her here.
Will you hold me?
Yeah.
Bye.
Alright, now she's just gonna play the song?
What is the doll gonna do?
Wait, I put the...
Okay, so she doesn't give a fuck, so I'm just gonna leave.
Oh, would war lady like her?
What are you here?
Oh wait, I need the sand- okay.
I don't know what to do now.
I got this down.
Okay.
And then I need sandwich.
Alright, we don't care about sister.
We don't care about...
Am I redeemable?
Exactly!
We don't need her!
Boom.
Eat your sandwich, stupid.
Here we go.
Alright.
Now rat's happy.
Whoa!
I'm not happy!
Alright, and then we gotta do this thingy.
Whoa, but wait, I need to drop this thingy.
Okay, so we settle on how to deal with dad first round.
How the fuck do I deal with dad second round?
Well, I don't know how to deal with dad second round.
So...
The cat!
Oh!
Alright, here, I'll hold you.
What the fuck do I do with you?
Alright, I drop you?
Here you go.
Alright, alright.
Okay, so all we have is just wait until midnight now.
Oh, Shadow Man!
I need you.
Oh, oh.
Do I save mom?
Pop!
I might as well.
I'm here.
Alright, and then I turn on the lights.
And then... Now what do I do?
I don't know what to do now.
I guess I wait?
Okay.
Dad!
I did everything I could!
Oh, Shadow Man!
Dad!
Oh...
Doll fell down.
Why did doll fell down?
Why did doll fall down?
I just want one ending, user.
I just want one ending.
Alright, daddy.
Alright, dad.
Now I'm waiting.
Daddy's home.
Alright, dad.
Just go into this trap.
Go into this trap.
Woop!
My mom!
Hey, dad!
I'm right here!
Woop!
What
the fuck was that?
I'm so sorry.
Thank you so much for the gift.
It's so to Acer.
Thank you for the birthday.
Real quick.
XA, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you so much for the follow.
I really appreciate it.
Alright.
You know what?
I don't know what the fuck I'm gonna do.
I can destroy the toilet in the bathroom.
Alright, let's destroy the fucking toilet with the bowling ball.
I was like, here, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Well, the doll was fucking useless.
We don't give a shit about the doll.
So she was useless.
Go into war?
But I can't make it into... I can't though.
Look.
It won't let me go in.
It's locked.
Mom won't let me in.
But it's so hard.
The rat's too fast for me.
The rat's too fast.
Okay, I'll show you guys.
I'll show you guys.
Look at this.
The rat's too good.
Look.
Alright.
Wait!
Oh, I'm a pro gamer!
I'm a fucking pro gamer!
Wait, wait a minute.
I'm a fucking pro gamer.
Oh shit!
Yeah!
I did it!
I'm so good!
Wait, do I need to see?
Oh, we don't give a fuck about mom anyway.
Wait, how do I go in?
Oh, I need the bowling ball.
I need the bowling ball.
I fucked up!
I didn't bring the bowling ball!
I fucked up.
I forgot the bowling ball.
I forgot the most important part.
Dude, I'm so fucking good.
I'm so good at this game!
Bam!
Who the fuck are you?
What do I do?
Do I...
I can't pick it up!
It won't let me...
What the fuck.
We don't give a shit.
Well, I guess... I guess he's dead.
Um,
I guess my mom's dead too.
I guess my mom's dead.
I
don't know what else to do anymore.
Oh, the shot!
The shotgun!
I forgot the shotgun in the closet!
You know, I might as well get bored.
Just bore me.
Alright, just like...
I need the shotgun.
No, no, no.
Okay, okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
Alright, we got this.
We got this.
I got this.
I know what to do now.
My brain has expanded.
I don't care about who else dies here.
I'm just...
I'm just accepting them for.
Yeah, but what do I need the lights on for?
Like, what do I need the lights on for though?
There's no reason to have lights on.
My brain has expanded today, guys.
Alright, watch this.
Watch this pro gamer.
Yeah, you thought...
You thought... I know how to play this game now.
You thought you got this?
I'm better.
I'm a better gamer.
Get the fuck away, mom.
Yeah.
Yeah, mom.
Yeah, get out.
Get out, mom.
Alright, and then I take the shotgun.
Alright, and then...
And then... bam.
Give me that.
And then...
I go...
Oh!
Well, I don't give a fuck about the sister.
I don't care about her.
Um, okay, so...
First off, I need the bowling ball for the bear trap.
Alright, I got all the...
Okay, okay, we don't care about the sister.
Like, I wanna be an only child.
Should I save mom?
Oh, I should save the cat though.
Alright, I'm gonna save the cat.
Break your toilet after getting the trap?
Why?
Well, this is...
What does the toilet do?
Yeah, but I don't care about the sister.
That doesn't do shit though, right?
What is this?
Hey, ducky.
Why would I do it with a ducky?
Okay, I need this.
Alright, alright.
Okay, so we got everything we need.
Alright.
And then...
We need the bear trap here.
Okay, and then...
And I guess I can watch my sister die.
The fucking timing on that!
Okay.
You're the That timing.
That timing.
Oh, god, that was perfect.
Yo, I'll save mom.
I'll save mom.
Who the fuck cares?
I'll save her.
Oh, that was actually perfect.
That was actually perfect.
Oh my god.
Yo, you did not give a fuck about the sister.
Please show up so I can chop your hands.
So I can go chop chop.
Chop chop.
Alright, alright.
All we have to do is wait for the dad, right?
We got everything.
Wait, I have to get shotgun ammo?
Oh, no!
I don't have shotgun ammo.
I didn't know!
No one told me about the shotgun ammo.
Well, I guess we're gonna get bored again, guys.
Guess we're gonna get...
No one told me.
Where is the shotgun ammo?
Okay, that...
There's no shotgun ammo here.
Where is it?
Where
are you, shotgun ammo?
No, that is...
I don't know where shotgun ammo is.
Shotgun ammo?
Oh, okay, well...
Well, I tried to find the shotgun ammo and that didn't work.
Well, then.
Okay, alright.
This is it.
This is gonna be the run.
We know everything.
Where the fuck is the shotgun ammo, though, guys?
Where the fuck is the shotgun ammo?
Please.
I need to know what...
I want this game to be over with.
Where is the gun ammo?
I just...
We just...
We know everything.
We just don't know one thing.
Our one flaw.
Shotgun ammo.
Please, I want this to be over with.
Alright,
alright.
And then we chop.
We chop.
Okay.
And...
Where the heck...
There's a gun ammo in the basement.
You need to bring it.
Break the face, though.
Okay.
We got all our information.
We got... Thank you.
I'm tired of getting bored.
I was tired of getting bored, guys.
Oh, I forgot to save my mom.
What the fuck do I do with a duck, though?
What was the point?
Of the duck.
You know what?
I'll go break this.
I'll go break it.
Yeah.
I'm so bored.
Alright, ducky.
What do I do with you?
Do I put the...
What if I put the duck next to... I'll put the duck next to the trap.
Oh, pfft.
Oh, you just chuck it, apparently.
Alright.
Okay, there we go.
I don't care about you.
Oh, so much time.
Alright.
And then pick up the sandwich.
I don't know what to do with that.
And then...
Alright, and then we gotta save ducky.
Alright, and then we gotta break the vase.
Boop.
And then one...
Alright.
Cat, I need you to...
Okay, okay, and then...
Woo!
How do I load the gun?
Is my gun loaded?
Alright, I'm gonna assume my gun's loaded.
I'm gonna assume...
Alright, we got everything!
We got everything!
One bullet!
Okay, maybe I don't...
Maybe I need more than one bullet.
Maybe I need more than one bullet, you know?
I don't trust myself.
Here you go, rat.
Alright, alright, alright.
I sort of don't trust myself here.
Oh!
Oh, I'm sorry!
Oh, no!
I killed a rat!
I accidentally chopped a rat.
Goddamnit!
I chopped a rat!
I was a perfect and then I killed his children.
We almost had the rat!
I had to chop the child!
I had to chop this child!
I'm sorry!
Oh wait...
It's the other option.
This word has changed you.
I'm sorry!
I just wanted to chop the... chop the fog!
Oh
you bitch!
Okay, and then chop chop!
Chop chop!
Oh I should put this down first before I chop chop.
Alright, chop chop.
Alright, bye mom!
Okay.
Chop!
Alright, alright, there we go.
We got the speedrun.
Do I even need...
Do I even need this?
I don't really need it.
As good as you're holding the axe you're holding.
I don't need you sister.
I don't need you.
I just need...
I just need ammo.
To load my shotgun.
Oh, can I kill her?
Oh, okay, no.
Alright, bye.
And then...
No, that's okay.
We don't need to save her.
Here, take this out.
How do I shoot it?
Oh, okay, wait, wait, wait.
Shadow man, please.
Shadow man, please!
Please, shadow man!
I just wanna do this!
Woo!
Shadow man, please!
Let me, I need more ammo!
Alright, two, two shotgun.
There we go, two shots.
We got this.
Two shots and a dream.
Oh, cat!
Cat, cat, cat, cat, cat!
Cat!
There we go.
Alright.
Did we say mom?
Let's just say mom for now.
Let's just say...
We're gonna take doll to the sister?
No, that's okay.
We don't need the sister.
Yeah, bitch.
Alright, alright.
We got everything we need.
We have the shotgun.
There we go.
Okay, okay.
We have everything.
We got everything we need!
Dad, come up!
Come here, dad!
Dad!
Woo!
Shadow!
Alright, alright, alright.
Alright, alright, daddy.
Alright, dad.
No, I'm not a doll.
I'm a sister.
That's why I'm an o- Why do you think I'm an only child, guys?
Why do you think I'm an only child, guys?
Alright, alright.
Come
in here.
Yeah!
I just have a mom!
We did it!
It only took us 30 minutes, guys.
All we need was two shots.
Dad's dead.
I get the house!
Oh, I have a cat too!
I'm a cat and rat!
I get the house!
The house is mine!
And a mom.
I guess that's alright.
Oh, shit.
It's time to listen to the daily song.
Okay, wait, wait.
Let's listen to the daily song.
Uh, let's, let's like embrace victory real quick.
The daily song.
Oh, the darkness retreats, but somewhere distant, a fleshy heartbeat continues.
We did it!
Woo!
You'll be the toast of the time, the girl on the- We did it!
More sandwiches!
Oh my god, we actually did it!
The fuck were you?
So you think you've beaten it?
Well, I'm afraid you're terribly wrong.
There's no way to stop it.
It never ends.
Whoop!
You know what?
You know what, doll?
I'm gonna end it right here.
I close my eyes.